[Musik]
gratulation und asset management tätig
dass die alte methode die zur aufnahme
aufschreiben hälfte auf 151 maximal zwei
drittel der zeit für plan entscheiden
also trinken wenn ich mich natürlich und
nachkontrollieren flügel hatte vom ende
von tag 4 5 bis 8
die eisenhower methode war deine
aufgaben nach dringlichkeit und
wichtigkeit richtige trinkende aufgaben
sofort erledigen unwichtige trägen der
aufgaben nach möglichkeit abgeben oder
später erledigen wichtigen ich trinke
aufgaben aufschreiben und späte
erledigen und musste mich dringende
aufgaben
finger weg die commodore methode eine
pro modul steht für eine arbeit einheit
von 25 minuten arbeit und 15
schreibt mir eine grüne überlegen wie
viel vom notorischen aufgabe frauen
stehe ein timer und los geht's typen von
guten arbeit sein kind aus die auf naki
und frische luft ein fleck oder
meinetwegen mit behörden kandidaten
arbeit und geweitet nach vier arbeit
einhalten könnten
zum beispiel eine pause mit videos
tatsächlich eine studie überhaupt das
kappen klubs unsere höhere und unsere
motivation sind ja dann wohl schaffen
mehr für prokrastination findet ihr auch
hier gefühlt weise unter dem weg in der
beschreibung schön schlapp